this has become a patreon video now
[Music]
so when we came in to just kidding news
today Walter here showed up and he's
like hey guys you guys should check this
out and I did
it's about a man who's just arrested for
beheading a young mother in the middle
of the street in America in San Carlos
California San Carlos because this is
some Middle East Behavior or some cartel
[ __ ] yeah sure yeah what's San Carlos at
because cartel is money driven but the
Middle East is like more like otter
driven so this was outside San Carlos is
up north this yeah this is up north this
is outside the victim's residence
um the victim had two kids who did not
thankfully witness the crime she was
pregnant the kids were inside the house
at the time however did I make that up
was she pregnant
um I don't know that she was pregnant
okay [ __ ] all right yeah I don't know
um
I just wanted to raise the stakes a
little bit I understand you're fine
it was just spelling bee champion
I know where you got that I don't think
she's Indian there's a lot of fake news
apparently coming out about
that um yeah so just before noon
um reports came in that the woman's head
was cut off by a [ __ ] sword Jesus do
you guys feel worse when they're
beautiful because I'm always like oh no
even though I'm not single but I'm like
not another one is it why is that you
think is it bad to feel that though I
feel I feel like guys all know what I'm
talking about or it's like no it's so
wasted you know like not like you ever
had a chance with her it just it's like
you have way more like simple but
doesn't the news do that too aren't they
like a beautiful woman whose life was
stop short to do that they do that and
you're like no not the beautiful one
please take the ugly one yeah aren't we
raised with that [ __ ] yeah the news
isn't like an ugly piece of [ __ ] thank
God
it is true because remember when that I
did a story about some girl who died at
like a factory walkthrough yeah nobody I
turned it around and nobody wanted to
say how hot she was yeah well hey we
were just like ah what a shame well
Anthony tried to because he's a
pandering [ __ ] but nobody really
believes but like it's the reason is
because like more attractive women tend
to have better societal advantages and
you would think damn she didn't have to
go through that because she had enough
road to dodge this [ __ ] life right
you didn't have to be a [ __ ] metal
worker what the [ __ ] are you doing
there's so many opportunities for you
yeah she also didn't have to be in a
beheading situation right so sad what
did she know the dude so she had filed a
restraining order against him
but the saddest piece of information is
that she had double d tits
that's even worse
you guys laid that [ __ ] crowd working
stupid [ __ ] they said they're natural
but you know what's cool though what
they said there it says their necks oh
you know what it feels like it feels
like I saw a million dollars and it just
lit in flames in front of my eyes and
I'm like why would you do that those are
good mommy milkers right there the best
part of this article is watching Ryan
May's eyes as everyone's saying wild
[ __ ] he just like what the [ __ ] is going
on in here
that's where anime's first JK did
because everyone's beating me to things
I want to say Ryan's like man if I was
there I would have I would have jumped
right in front of the sword and saved
her yeah no you don't want to get in the
way because as it's slicing the Boozer
just jiggling around Ryan would have
been like this you'd have been like
that there's so much truth and what
Walter just said because some guy out
there is like getting a stream oh what a
waste I could have saved her and we
could have fell in love because at the
end of the day all guys are [ __ ]
thinking about is trying to Bone the
hell and fall in love no being a hero
and then parlaying that into boning the
chicken yeah that's the best that's
that's the Pinnacle it's so stupid
that's what James Bond does yeah no we
don't talk about it though because no
before you guys asked who my dream was
of course my dream is to be a hero and
meet a woman you know and save her with
all that but we don't talk about it
because it's understood I was like
buying a car with lifetime warranty
right yeah dude you're like three years
from becoming Mr glass dude right yeah
you're gonna be you're gonna be the
villain who creates the scenario to get
the woman and then she's married to you
for 20 years and she finds out the
horrible truth because because like
girls also have this like I need to save
him but like guys it's a different one
guys is like you're walking down the
[ __ ] you're at a park and [ __ ] girls
skateboarding [ __ ] trips and she
falls and you grab her and [ __ ] she goes
oh you [ __ ] rescue me let me suck
your dick it's because guys are so lazy
we just want to save you once girls are
like I want to save him like so many
times and like try to save all his
friends
him and make all the positives come out
guys are like didn't I save you like
four years ago come and suck my dick
please yeah you hold over their head
yeah there is something too like I was
reading this do you guys watch the show
the locator
or to find the finder I'm so it's called
The Finder anyway it was based on a book
where this guy he was a special forces
guy but his his thing was is finding
things but in the book he saves this um
woman's life he doesn't kill her because
he had every reason to kill her but he
doesn't and he knew he goes once you do
that for a woman she feels indebted to
you and she's basically yours you know
and I was like I wonder if this is a
chauvinistic or misogynistic thing but
then later this girl comes around and
goes I know you saved me and so right
now I don't know what to do whether to
sleep with you or to leave you and like
they got me thinking there is something
to we don't talk about it because none
of us are safe or is it biological maybe
like instinctive type of thing oh I'd
say live before but you have yeah yeah
I've saved someone's life and they keep
throwing their puss at you no no it was
it wasn't that situation what was it was
it was it PS4 or Xbox nah it was like
some kid fell in a pool when he was
drowning and I saved him dude there is a
weird I would I would say like
regardless of who it is male or female
right there is a weird vulnerable human
connection that happens when you do help
somebody yeah in the form of whether it
be charity or like physical harm or
something when you're helping someone
sometimes a complete stranger or
whatever there is a weird connection
that exists that's a a moment of
intimacy yeah so imagine when it's a
life like you're saying and it's a hot
girl if you combine that it's like oh
we're in love we don't know each other
but we're in love for like 30 seconds
sure is that who is drowning in your
story no it was it was a small child I
did save this
can you tell us that story what the [ __ ]
I don't want to talk about it dude it's
very private but no I was like I was
like 11 or something and you saved the
dog no some kid fell in the pool and I
[ __ ] it wasn't a big deal so it
wasn't as an adult
but as an adult I did find someone's pit
bull walking around in the street and I
picked it up and then I brought it I
found the people and I brought it back
to him and then the next day they
brought me ice cream so I could only
imagine that's very cool what would it
would be like if I saved a woman's life
you know what I mean I'm for sure gonna
be marrying that person yeah no see I
really mean dead it to me for sure no
wait you were talking about Joe like the
connection you make but when it's
exponentially magnified to the life then
it's like
yeah yeah then they can't leave you and
have some excuse no they can't say oh
you know we had irreconcilable
differences like no if you save somebody
they become your property immediately
exactly yeah exactly that's exactly what
it is like a woman like when I was in
college yeah I knew nothing about like
picking up women or anything but I was
like The Lazy Man's way to fall in love
it really no it really is dude because
like this girl she saved me from I flew
off my skateboard
and in my I was in the air midair I was
prepared to like push her out of the way
because I was going to land on her she
was like No And she caught my hands so
you wouldn't help yes right when she
like caught my hands my feet touched and
I landed like right in front of her and
I stopped right she's in college now in
if it was like as like an adult adult
I'd been like hey thank you so much like
what's your name she was shocked that I
stopped right in front of her like we
were both shocked at our physical
prowess at that level she owns you and
did you go in for a kiss and the thing
is as I was so like ignorant with all
that stuff I thought I didn't get her
name nothing but if this happened now I
get her name or number or Instagram I
get everything you get too much yeah I
get too much yeah you know but like that
I knew nothing of that but I was in a
situation we do want kids immediately
exactly so you fell like that and you
said thank you yeah I was just the first
thing I said was are you okay because I
in my mind she was scared that I was
gonna plow into her which is what I
would have done because which is what
you would have done later you know yeah
number one number one yeah but yeah like
that happened too early in my life was
she attractive I remember she was like
she wasn't like hot but she was like the
attractive like you want to date her
yeah
you don't want to marry the hot ones how
did this lady get into this beheading
situation yeah that's very what does the
article say I don't know no
she tried she tried to put a restraining
order against this guy right and then he
ends up coming to her house with the
saber
she she was being harassed by him
multiple times yes she files a report
saying she wants a restraining order it
was taking a while how come it didn't
work the restraining orders are kind of
[ __ ] the search for the weapons
still ongoing the suspects suffer
suffered a medical emergency of some
sort afterwards details are limited
because they had the guy they had the
guy in custody but uh details are very
limited it's very early it's just
[ __ ] happened so yeah restraining
order is a [ __ ] joke against a guy
who's willing to go to jail for cutting
your head off yeah dude what the [ __ ] I
think he probably he probably tried to
stab himself after because you know like
when you had those mass shootings
they'll be like oh the shooter killed
himself after I think it's because it
set it sets in now what he what that
person just did yeah and he can't they
can't take that pressure and then they
shoot them they kill themselves I think
this guy probably did this and he goes
what the hell did I just do but he cut a
whole head off that's kind of how do you
even get a sword out of the car and then
walk up to the church crazy I'm just
saying I just think at least she didn't
have a gun because maybe she could have
accidentally shot somebody who's behind
him oh thank God she didn't have a gun
to shoot anybody yeah you know what the
irony is it's actually legal to carry a
sword like like so the way the law is
written is is that for foldable knives
that whole hand thing is BS like if you
have it in your pocket if the clip
sticking out it's okay but you can't
have a folding knife in your pocket
without the clip showing you it's
concealed at that point now a sword a a
non-foldable knife as long as it's
sheath you can have it on your person
what so like that sword you can legally
carry it around as long as it's sheath
that's like it's a weird way the law is
Rich you can't have nunchucks I saw a
fat ninja
there was a fat ninja in Hawaii he was
riding a moped bed with a [ __ ] ninja
sword I mean yeah like a katana behind
them yeah yeah and then he had he had a
tank top on that was really tight and
just rolls just hanging out and then
dreadlocks too dude if you have a good
sauna on your person's red flag I mean
yeah then Chuck it's worth they say it's
worse to have a nunchucks like legally
speaking than a gun yeah in your car
which is beyond me because nunchucks do
the most damage to yourself yeah
Alyssa Bruce Lee yeah and if you and if
you like you've curated the skills to be
really good with nunchucks guess what
you're a [ __ ] loser
that's exactly that's exactly right it
wasn't it was a so there were certain
weapons like this or nunchucks or
whatever right they were the choice of
gangs in the 60s so to punish them to
the highest his West Side Story days
dude it was like
get them with that yeah but like guns
are cool yeah you can have a gun but
like nunchucks Oh no you're You're gone
for like x amount of years was this dude
this guy was this is a [ __ ] felony
camera we gotta blur this out this has
become a patreon video now because well
this is definitely a patreon video I'll
tell you that right now I'll tell you
that right now that was a close call man
monetize for that
[Music]
thank you
[Music]